les sirènes rythment le quotidien des
habitants
la ville a déjà été bombardée à
plusieurs reprises en périphérie son
centre reste pour l'heure préservé mais
ceux qui vivent encore ici n'oublie pas
que la guerre est à leur porte
tout le monde a peur c'est normal hein
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
ici personne n'est à l'abri les bombes
peuvent tomber n'importe où et on peut
se faire tuer on ne peut pas fuir la
guerre
à quelques kilomètres de là le front se
rapproche de plus en plus marque motel
une des dernières grandes villes d'udon
de basse encore sous contrôle
l'ukrainien cet octogénaire qui a
toujours vécu ici peine encore à
réaliser
je me souviens de la seconde guerre
mondiale j'étais petit à l'époque
maintenant ici aussi c'est l'horreur
depuis plusieurs jours les évacuations
se succèdent sur 73 mille habitants
trente mille aurait quitté la ville
depuis le début du conflit souvent des
familles entières qui prennent la route
de dnipro à 4h10 si
il y a deux semaines en évacuer 10 à 15
personnes par jour
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment le double
beaucoup de personnes âgées préfèrent
rester car elles n'ont nulle part où
aller